hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i'm
here guys to make a big update on
gamestop gme not moving much guys the
past week that's true but we are in a
nice situation something might happen
soon so let's analyze everything that we
have and see what can happen next let's
get into it
[Music]
oh right guess as usual daily time frame
so what is the situation here we have
gamestop that is all right where can i
start bam bam bam okay we i am on the
regular scale right now and we having
this breakout guys that i have analyzed
with you already uh last week i'm gonna
go through that quickly again but what i
want to point out in this video guys is
this right here look what we have this
is similar to what we had here right
this is called a consolidation guys
right we're consolidating as you can see
and for consolidation to be good
we need to have low volume right this is
key i'm not gonna explain here why the
slow volume are very important
but look here this is a perfect
consideration this between here and here
i hope you see well guys between 21st of
deck to 7th of jan because look at the
low volume that we had here it's similar
to the low volumes we had each time
there was a trend shift all right guys
low volume consolidations
precedes trend shifts look here
here here
here and we're having a one right now
guys so once again i know i'm repeating
that in all of my videos recently but
guys i built a course that i've been
working on for the past six months
it's really like amazing content you're
gonna love it i'm explaining guys how to
understand the price action dynamics
guys it's going to be about that and
seriously it's going to help you a lot
to improve your results what i'm going
to show you guys in this course you
can't find this on the internet i mean
you can't find it but it's not going to
be explained the way i do it with many
examples it's really a big big big work
that i have achieved guys and i'm really
happy that i'm done with that by the way
it took me a lot of time and it's not on
your course guys you're going to get
have access to a place you know with
members a little bit like discord but
it's going to be a different place where
i want to bring some experienced traders
that are going to help you to use the
course guys and to really you know trade
the way you should be trading all right
this is my project guys so if you're
interested just click on the link in the
description of this video and you're
going to receive a 50 discount only at
the beginning and those who have
subscribed will get the discounters who
have not subscribed they might still get
a discount but it's gonna be lower and
i'm not sure how i'm gonna handle that
you know it's new for me it's the first
time i do i do this but uh trust me it's
gonna be amazing and if you don't like
it you are fully refunded all right so
you can't say that i'm trying to take
your money guys i'm just trying to bring
you some good good content that's gonna
help you all right and you don't like it
you you get your money back no problem
so let's go back to what i was saying
those considerations and of course i'm
explaining that very well in my course
are key guys to know when a reversal is
gonna come so this is the reason why
this breakout for me was not extremely
good quality
by the way it was better than amc i just
analyzed amc before so yesterday's video
here you see we have this consolidation
the consideration doesn't need to be in
the horizontal range it can be here the
consolidation i mean it can go down a
consideration is considered as valid as
long as it is close to support or
resistance so here we have a resistance
on the top a support on the bottom so we
are conciliating between a support and a
resistance here we have a resistance
that you can see here the pink uh
downward sloping trend line and the
support is here guys all right i can
draw it sorry i put a lot of drawings
but you know i can add the trend line if
you prefer to make it clean and this is
the same thing guys we are in a tight
range so you don't care if it's inclined
or not it's still a reconciliation area
all right so what i was saying is that
right now we have this so what we need
guys now to know what the next move
might be is a signal so signal might
come from many different can take
different shapes it can look differently
but a breakout for example is a very
good signal so we're going to monitor
that and to find what is the breakout
level you can pay attention to where
exactly the resistance is so here
definitely guess the 120 level i'm
talking about this level i think for the
past
seriously maybe even six months guys now
i was talking about 135 six months ago
but now i'm talking about 120 for a very
long time guys and you can see that this
is a very serious resistance level let
me put it back where it was so i think
that if we close above 130 this is what
i'm saying on my discord guys we will go
to 160 quickly all right this is going
to be explosive why explosive because we
are at this low volume okay so the
investors are excited the market is in
the wait and see mode and it's just
waiting for trigger you know what i mean
so if we close above 130 a lot of
traders are gonna jump in this trade
including myself
so this is my take but we might also
close below 115. so what could happen
below 115 yeah and also we have the
50-day moving average coming here guys
so we have a double resistance okay you
see it in pink here so double resistance
level that if we close above is gonna
attract uh moving averages uh breakout
traders and trend trendline breakout
traders all right so you you want to
attract as many investors as possible in
your trade so that your reversal signal
is successful here breakout and on the
downside guys what do we have we have
this moving average coming 111 so i'm
paying attention to that guys uh you
know 20 period moving averages are
followed a lot by a lot of traders so i
think that we might come here just like
on amc guys i've done mcs today so the
level is around 117 so i think we might
come to 11516
on gamestop 110
you know something between
111 and 115 quickly be both and then
rebound okay and hopefully close above
130 and go further now i was telling you
guys if we have this close here we're
going to go to 160 then probably reject
it and do something like that or maybe
go lower i don't know it's too early to
say guys
and if we close below 115 what can
happen so as i just said we have the
20-day moving average coming here so we
would need to close below that 20-day
moving average for a signal to be valid
for me and as you can see we don't have
something that is really clear so as it
is not clear uh bears might not be able
to take control on this and plus we have
a medium term bullish signals with this
breakout so my take is that whatever
happens you know it's going to be both
all right
right now i don't see game stop going
below 200 level
you know 105 might be the bottom for now
because once again i have this breakout
that is telling me that there are a lot
of bulls here guys all right
boo's are waiting okay i don't know if
you're waiting there but i do and i
think that a lot of us are waiting there
guys all right
around this levels okay we are here guys
okay this is where we are so yeah i
think that on the medium term i don't
see any any real trouble that could
happen to gamestop i think the troubles
are behind us guys and one once again
i've been saying for a long time that we
might go to 87 all right since we have
this breakout that is not perfect but
good quality enough
i think that we are a bit out of trouble
so let's see maybe i'm gonna be wrong i
don't know but you know for the past two
three months i'm very accurate i think
on my predictions i was wrong right here
that's true guys it was very hard here
to to see exactly what would happen i
got trapped in this bull trap here so
i'm not saying that i'm always correct
i'm just saying that for the past two
three months guys i think i gave you
very good levels very good predictions
so
let's see if i if i still have the
correct view for the coming weeks so
once again i sum up my view
i think we're going to consider it a
little bit more maybe find some support
around
1115 level and then finally go above 130
break it guys with volume here i want to
see the volume going lower guys i want
to see a volume breakout just like we
had here okay
low volume then volume breakout at this
level and then if we close above 130 we
i think we're gonna rally quickly to 160
then get rejected and then we will see
guys so that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys